yeah that's never no one's ever asked me
that before it's pretty good there's
science education like comedy well you
want to get people to choose choose to
embrace it you always want the student
to figure it out for her or himself you
don't want to give her or him the answer
if you can help it
and maybe that's actually maybe that's
an excellent analogy to the Steve
Martin's point was as I understand it as
I understand it was it the funniest time
is when you say well you had to be there
you had to be there and then the reason
for that was because you've chosen to
laugh you have picked a time to laugh so
if you challenge the student to come up
with the answer for her or himself then
he's chosen to do that she has chosen to
get the answer and so it it makes it
your own
as we say having somebody do it for
themselves it's worth being told about
it a thousand times and so what you want
to do is arrange science education so
that students have hands-on experiences
and everybody talks about this all the
time
but it's a whole nother thing to
actually pull it off to actually do it
that way
you